[Music]
what an absolutely
uh what a lady man do I have a absolute
layer for you guys for this one today's
guess is arguably one of the greatest
fullbacks to ever play the game he
started off as a hawkes-based sensation
who quickly became a crusader Legend who
then went on to become an all black
great this man has had some Journey and
it's not just on the footy field either
where he's also excelled since footy
where he's become a radio and TV star
hosting sins Morning Show as well as
doing TV commentary and has even
recently starred in his own TV show with
Beaver Clubhouse rescue and as you
already know this man's on this podcast
for a good reason he is one of the
greatest Lads in the country it is the
one and only Israel dag welcome mate oh
how you doing Jimmy Marlo it's an
absolute privilege to be on this podcast
I love it because you actually you're
making a difference and you're telling
good stories that I think can can make a
hell of a lot of difference and I think
it's only fitting you know I'm just the
normal lad that I had a had an awesome
time throwing the pillow around and
going on a journey around around the
world but uh post footy just living life
and and just really want to share the
story and man I think you do fantastic
to follow with Timmy Bateman I must have
been I get nervous at the best times but
followed on Timmy B hopefully I can uh
share some some wisdom and some gravy
for you right out there listening oh
mate you do have one of the best
Journeys uh out there but you did you
mentioned before that yeah you hadn't
been on another podcast before so super
grateful for choosing what land is your
your first ever I've been asked to share
the story plenty of times and um look
I've been I've only really just jumped
into to the podcast I'm still quite new
and and still haven't you know spread my
wings and trying to listen to podcasts
but I obviously listen to Timmy B's and
and obviously uh listen to Fati loafers
one and obviously the injuries that he
went through and I just think it's it's
a perfect kind of platform for myself to
share the journey and share the stories
and yeah I was thinking on the way here
I was how much do I actually share like
yeah when you put that that question
what do you want to ask as you dag I was
like oh my God
demons are gonna come out up from
nowhere and someone's gonna have some
sort of question but I'll be open I'll
be vulnerable and I'll I'll share it and
yeah look it's been an interesting time
since I've retired it's probably been
probably the most difficult time in in
my 34 years of of age so uh yeah I've
just jumped into new industry was was so
um broadcasting and
spreading my wings on TV and trying to
trying to make a living it's um yeah I
was listening to Timmy B and talking
about the transition out of rugby it's
yeah it's a it's a difficult one man and
you probably think and people on the
outside look think oh you know he's
corrected he's he's doing well but mate
honestly I'm far from far from the
finished product and you know there's
still a lot of Doubt sex creep into my
mind of why I'm doing this what am I
doing now who am I yeah you know I'm as
he dead you rattle off all the stats but
um when you finish you're like wow who
am I really um Amazon the former rugby
player what am I going to be now yeah
you know right it's crazy because like
like you say from the outside looking
and you're one of the guys who I'd put
right up there as someone who's
absolutely nailed their life after rugby
transition you pretty much went from
rugby straight into TV and then radio
when you had shows and you know you're
like this big personality New Zealand
celebrity
um but deep down yeah you say you're
struggling during that time losing your
identity as Israel dag the the Superstar
fullback yeah well it's just one of
those things because everyone knows you
as he dag the rugby player they're all
black 66 you played test for the for
your country the Crusaders yeah yeah I'm
looking along the walls at some of the
greats and that was a small part of my
life and a big part that most people
will know me is and it's quite hard
because when you finish that's all taken
away and you're like okay
so what now what are people going to
remember me as now um I am the former
player I am ahead of speed I am a washed
up former athlete but I've got to try
and jump into this other industry and
I'll be completely honest I don't think
I was going to be in broadcasting yeah
um I never went oh I never went to
broadcasting school I hardly ever went
to school and actually paid attention to
blood myself so that was obviously at
the back of my mind but um I guess the
one thing I tried to do when I was
playing is
has never changed your way who I am as a
person like you can get caught up in it
and I'll be completely awesome I got
caught up in the in the Limelight in the
spotlight and filled my ship didn't
stink and you know you get a bit carried
away and it wasn't until you get dealt a
bit of adversity that actually brings
you back and stop trying to make sure
you realize okay
I'm actually not as cool as I think I am
so you still have those those doubts
creeping in and uh broadcasting was
probably
way way outly filled for me I thought I
thought I'd go get a trade or or just go
get a normal nine today nine to five job
and just do something but I guess for me
I wasn't shy of who I was and who I am
and they saw the potential of me and and
gave me an opportunity to transition so
I'm very grateful for sky sport that
giving me that platform to allow me to
finish when I was forced to retire you
know I retired at 30. I know young at a
young age and it was not what I wanted I
thought I'd still be planning especially
seeing Samuel like I've made my debut
who was Sammy while I'm still carbonate
what about Willie Hines
like honestly like these boys are just
still going on and not looking a day
over 30 like it's so good but um yeah my
career got cut short and I try and tell
players these days
um
to try and really to plan for that that
life when it's all going to get come you
know all gonna end not when you when you
want it to him but it's going to end
someday and and if you don't plan for it
man it can be scary and I know you'll
have plenty of messages yeah in regards
to Timmy Bateman's like when you finish
it's like what now you know you got
60 or maybe 50 odd years where you've
got to live and you've got to earn yeah
and you've got to make crust and you've
got kids you got to pay bills and put
food on the table it's that's difficult
and you set yourself up pretty well
financially for that transition or were
you under we under pressure straight
away um I was lucky man I was very very
lucky throughout my career and it wasn't
until I met one of my best mates
um you'd probably know I'm Kirk Gibbons
up in Auckland was it yeah he's a wizard
so before then I thought owning a house
was the end and don't get me wrong like
having your own house having your own
bit of land is
is amazing that's that's a wonderful
achievement but that's where my mind was
at and I was very just I just had a
really narrow mindset of of life after
the footy and it wasn't until I met him
and he kind of opened my mind up and
expanded my mind to to dream big and to
to try and work towards
um bigger and making life in that
transition afterwards so having him in
my side and having him um directing me
and just hitting me in the right
direction kind of made that transition
for life after 40 a whole lot easier and
I'll be completely honest but at the end
of the day like you never really settled
you're never really comfortable in all
reality we've all got to work and we all
want to just retire you know they say
retirement at 34 you retire when I
retired at 30. yeah I retired but it
really does you still got to have
something to get you out of bed yeah and
motivate you and and you know you still
got to pay bills man then that's that's
the reality so yeah meeting him made
life a whole lot easier but uh you
shouldn't just stop there yeah you've
got to continue
to Bitter yourself to be better and
educate yourself like I'm still trying
to educate myself on a daily learn and
and understand who I am as a person I
don't think I'll ever
get to that situation when I'll finally
cracked it and I've made it yeah I think
everyone's still on that journey and it
was your knees that forced you to retire
wasn't it yeah it was my knee so
um I've got knock knee so my knees out
of line most people are bowlegged my
knee actually goes the other way it goes
the other way
um so I've got bone on bone I've got no
cartilage everything's um just really
bone of Bones like bruises it swells and
that forced me to retire when I had no
cartilage in my last two years I was
hanging on but I thread it wasn't for
the help of is that when you're in Japan
yeah Japan man Japan full of Canon
people in Japanese they thought they had
silence Superstar from from New Zealand
but the reality is I was just going over
to get a little paycheck I'm not gonna
lie I'm not gonna lie I went over and
and I played over there and it wasn't
until
um like that I couldn't even step a
front row like I've got a lot of respect
for our front rows but as an outside
back you should step them up every
single time yeah and beat them
one-on-one over there I couldn't even do
that and it wasn't until I went to kick
this morning I used to love kicking the
ball and try and snap it smack it down
the field but it wasn't until over there
I went to kick the ball went 10 meters
and afterwards I couldn't really walk
and flew back seen the surgeon he said
look you gotta retire the only operation
you can do to fix it is called an
osteotomy so I'm getting osteotomy in in
May basically they cut my knee open they
break my femur put a wedge in it and
they put a plate on the inside yeah and
they realign it and then 10 years later
I gotta get a whole new knee that's
right so I'll be 44 with a little still
near my and my kneecaps so uh it's uh
it's it's been a process and that's the
thing I struggle with right now I've
always been active but since I finished
I've been immobile and being able to
move as as much so I'd like and as much
as I had
um put on a lot of weight and you
struggle so I'm going to get this
operation so I can just get some
normality back like simple things you're
a father my daughter was like can you
can you go on your knees and be a horse
yeah I'm like I can't even go on my
knees darling she's like what you're
young I'm like yeah well I feel like I'm
60 darling come on so I just want to be
able to do that just simple things with
my kids yeah go outside and chase them
around the backyard
and I said to him one day you'll never
beat me son so I still gotta try and
still trying to try and get some some
gas back in these legs so he can work
hard till he till he beats me one day
once you get that new now you're gonna
be back at it it's a horse around the
around the around the backyard yeah mate
that's uh I'm looking forward to getting
it done May 23rd I'll be out for six
months yeah it's a long recovery I'm on
crutches for like three months
non-weight
um but just just need to get it done so
I can just do normal things as a father
yeah I think that's my greatest
achievement today everyone asked me is
what you know you've achieved so much
want to World Cup you've you've you know
won titles for Super Rugby and and
what's what and whatever but being a
father it's my greatest it doesn't
compare Nothing Compares brother like
going home after a [__] game or on the
Rugby field you go home and they laugh
yeah and you know they don't even care
what they know
if only they knew how much I'm getting
sprayed by the general public out there
in New Zealand and they don't even you
know care about anything so it's so cool
did you miss 40 did you miss it once you
had to retire
uh it's a question I get asked all the
time do you miss it I I I don't miss the
games yeah I don't miss scan out there
and and watching these players today
like you always say you talk to a lot of
the old players that have played and
they've passed on and and you know
handed the Baton down it's I can't keep
up well it's true yeah the game is
evolving every single day these players
like looking at the skills of some of
these forwards like they're all playing
like back so they can move like back so
I do not miss plan yes particularly in
Fiji
it would have been horrible plan over
there
um but I must miss the boys you know
yeah I just walked in then and checked
out my old seat in the change room
severe Reese has it oh you know just
those are the times yeah you know you'd
know like in that change room we're just
about to go out in a nice
eight degree day in Christchurch and
you're just having a laugh the boys are
playing music and you know you know
you're sitting for one goal as to go
down there you're training hard and you
want to get the win in the end but for
me it was just during the week and I'm
still one of those Hangar owners with
the lads you know I'll still catch up
with David Harvey and Richie Morgan and
a few of the boys much drumming because
um I just like to stay involved with the
lads and seeing how they're going but uh
yeah I must I must have been around this
this room it's quite cool to come in and
brings back a lot of memories that's
what everyone says it's not the footy
it's not the mean
that's the boys and and the mates that
you meet along the way as such well I
just saw things like everyone said why'd
you jump at the sky sport I'll be
completely honest when I finish rugby I
hated rugby yeah I was like I want to do
something else this thing has been my
life since I was 17. I want to try
something different and then I got given
a sky sport job to go and talk about
Skye and I'll go talk about rugby uh on
a different level so yeah like I I must
miss the boys I still enjoy watching
rugby but uh yeah I don't miss the game
that much and you finished at Sky now or
you're still doing yeah so I'll finish
that sky sport so I had four years uh
post score and it was a tough decision
for myself to to make that decision but
when I got this radio gig I was working
every morning and then on the weekends
like my kids are five and four now
they're playing sport like I'd have to
fly to Auckland and it when I first
started it was awesome you know you go
up see your mates you get to go watch a
front row seat to the best games of
rugby but then as time got on and my
kids grew and their Sports become the
priority on the weekend I just had to
make that decision and it was a tough
decision but I just had to back myself
and uh and turn down the opportunity to
work for sky sport so I the one door
closes another one opens up and now I'm
just filming the old TV show around New
Zealand China
renovate clubs around the country with
my good mate Stephen Donald and uh yeah
and then soon we're about to head off to
France and and film another show over
there so one door closes another one
opens that one's a little bit more
lenient like I can go up to Auckland
during the week film it with my radio
kit so I can cover those two bases and I
still get the weekends at home sure so
so it's it accommodates so how does
what's can you what can you tell us
about this next TV show over in France
you're on Beaver oh ah look at I I'm not
I'm unsure I got an email the other day
if I can share a lot about it but me and
beaver just head over to France and uh
jump in the car and travel around and
and just see the sights sure yeah it's
going to be pretty cool watch
um two absolute clowns yeah just
traveling around and seeing a bit of the
world and it's you know it's fitting
because the World Cups here later in the
year and you'll get to see where the
best teams in the world are going to be
situated and uh basically it's got
nothing to offer rugby
absolutely nothing rugby a couple of
clowns just traveling around and uh send
some sights are you in control of the
content or how does that all work well
we've got a crew we've got a crew but um
it's basically we got an itinerary
beavers looking after one part and I'm
looking after another part and basically
we just said we just go along and yeah
the world's our oyster yeah see what
comes through the content mate so a
month away it sounds all good I'm gonna
miss my kids yeah but
um yeah it should be fun right so you
are basically the new Mark Allison
beavers Matthews I'm not they're funny
so those boys are actually quite funny
and they're very witty so it's a hard
act to follow but um we'll do our best
just go over there and tell our wise
we're working and everyone asks a
question are they there's a family
coming I said no child's name we might
as well go for free if they're coming
it should be fun oh man it's gonna be
good stuff it's going to be a good watch
no doubt but mate um we haven't even got
to the start of it let's let's start to
this at the start for you so um growing
up I don't know too much about you
before I met you at New Zealand under
19s always remember that but do you
remember spraying me in that game
Crusaders okay as Crusaders you were
warming me up man I've always wanted to
talk to you about it you've got under my
skin so much oh really irritating that's
me right we've skipped the whole thing
we've gone straight there so so I had to
bring I've been wanting waiting years to
get this opportunity
but you know who my influence was my
whole career at the canes
Dan jock Dan Coles and Corey James get
on the dead skin you get them easy I
remember that too because you know what
um Ryan karate afterwards I think I like
slept across the back of the head or
something and then he said I'll get out
of here you gray-haired old man I was
like real
[Laughter]
you don't you got me there I must admit
you got me anyone every time I play the
canes I just want to take the hits off
because they're all my best mates and it
worked every time because it took me
away from playing the game
oh there would have been some good
memories from playing the games too I
remember uh bad memories
I came up in the questions the bus the
bus tackle what do you remember about
that obviously well not much
he let him wow
he just said touch we're not playing
touch with rugby toads and you've got
him at Full Steam and then Robbie from
was tired and I was like come on Robbie
cover up and then I just got him at
Ballston what I remember is I was
thinking oh no here we go look
Jacqueline wasn't uh the best part of my
game I must be completely honest but I
had to try and make an attempt and it
was the worst attempt I've ever had to
make and wasn't just that one he
actually bumped me twice in that game
and it was a highlight reel that stole
to this day goes on yeah and what makes
it worse is my brother-in-law's and my
sister-in-law's son
constantly watches it yeah and I'm
getting irritate on my mate you get
outside I'm Gonna Bump you he's only
eight
oh
wasn't my proudest moment but anyway
right it's one of those things I think
it comes on the highlights real hey and
every year the Hurricanes play the
Crusaders there's always a memory in sky
sport when I was broadcasting would play
it I needed to be part of your contract
delete that footage whoever's in the
back room but uh yeah it was good times
but hurricanes they always had the ball
over me constantly got on my head and I
know what you're doing I know what
you're doing well anyway let's get to
let's get to the start let's get to the
start of Israel dagg's life where'd you
grow up what was it like I had an
interesting life I um I grew up in and I
was actually born in Martin and in
Martin's by wanganui there and I've
never been back I was only there for a
week true yes born and gone born and
gone the hospital's not even there the
hospital's gone but you know the stories
that are being told is my family wrote
it on the horse picked us up on the
horse and then rode back we actually
lived in a place called Norman Brewery
which is down the watoto valley
um Glen Osborne oh yeah yeah so we lived
we grew up there for a while and then
well hey look a pretty disruptive life
um mum and dad you know break up and and
get back together so there was a lot of
moving around we moved back to Hawkes
Bay
parked up in the bay for a couple of
years went to school there and then mum
and dad split up and and dad went to
Gisborne and uh and then we stayed in
the Hawke's Bay and then they got back
together and then we moved to wairau and
then lived in white or four at the
freezing where he worked at the freezing
Works in Whitehall and then we moved to
a place called fraserstown which is just
out of uh while there and then they
split up again and then Dad went to
Gizzy and then we went back to Hawkes
Bay with mum I was the youngest brother
of the family and my younger sister we
stayed with mum so I was the mama's boy
hard yeah and um yeah they split up for
a couple of years so pretty disruptive
and then mum and dad got back together
again all right and um and then we all
had a family back in the Hawke's Bay and
I've got a big family yeah I've got 11
brothers and sisters have you yeah true
yeah I gotta I got a big family so five
in the immediate family I'm the youngest
brother I've got a younger sister I've
got two other sisters that live in
Gisborne yeah so how that happened his
mom and dad split up and then Dad got
with another lady Liz and I had two
younger sisters
that had young kids with this lady Liz
and their names are Shona and Cassandra
and then apparently there's two other
young twins then I've never met really
that I've never met that live in
dannevirke apparently so
my sisters met them and said they look
exactly like us and they're like exactly
like Dad
um but I've never met them so apparently
they're a part of our family but anyway
and then they break up Dad and this
other lady with these two kids and then
they Mum and Dad get back together
[Music]
and then they got married about
six or seven years ago and they lived
happily until uh mum passed away about a
year and a half ago so uh
yeah interesting upbringing man so how
come you haven't met the the twins oh I
don't know yes funny oh well Dad says he
lost but they're out they're they're as
kids apparently and um I've just never
had an opportunity to to meet them my
sisters made an effort I've always been
down here so they live in denevik which
is up in North Island and we've never
just really touched base so yeah yeah
they kind of haven't been a part of our
family which is sad if they're our
sisters we love them
to be a part of the family but um yeah
they're kind of not but hopefully we can
touch base and and reconnect because
they are obviously our blood and yeah
and a big part of effort so we've got a
huge family mate 28 grandkids wow we're
a bunch of breeders I've only got two so
you can imagine all the breeding in the
family
um so Christmas is a full noise full-on
kids everywhere kazis it's um it's good
times but look we didn't have many much
things growing up yeah you know
disrupted but one thing we had was weird
love we had support and we had a lot of
care for for us as kids we never got any
uh we never got abused we never got any
sort of
uh things that go on in other households
um we just just had a lot of moving
around and moving Parts but we always
maintained our love and and our parents
and worked extremely hard to give us all
kids the best opportunity in life
um yeah mum worked three or four jobs
studied dad was up in the forestry
constantly I'm grinding away and
although they there was a lot of
disruption
they always gave us a platform and gave
us an opportunity and we always never
forget that but it's a wonderful it's an
interesting story and I I quite like to
share it because
um you know everyone has a different
movie
and whether that's a nice movie with
smooth sailing they've got all
everything they could ever dream of
whether it's on the other side where
you've got nothing you've got a lot of
disruption like if you believe in and
you dream and you work extremely hard
it's something that you're very
passionate about like anything can
happen or you don't need
all the materials I tell a story plenty
of times of not even having the right
people doesn't start playing rugby until
I was like nine or ten years of age oh
true yeah I was a late bloomer because
mum mama's boy well I couldn't afford a
rugby ball couldn't afford a rugby ball
couldn't afford boots uh we used to use
a slipper as a rugby ball all right out
in our front yard so my brother
he bought us a new partner home and she
bought some new slippers and we we
grabbed their new slippers and we were
playing on the front yard kicking her
brand new pink slippers through the
power pole there's a power pole standing
up and there was a fence on the side and
that is through my goal post so I'll be
kicking it in the [__] come home
screaming what are you slippers we just
kicked them through so that was one of
our rugby balls another one was um just
pillowcase used to fill the pillowcase
up with close and tie the end on it oh
yeah and then just get out the front
yard and use that so
yeah materials or any sort of you know
cricket bats just cut a piece of wood up
yeah and use that tie a bit of cell tape
on on the on the tennis ball and use
that as our nut for for backyard Cricket
light that's the thing as kids doesn't
matter what we had we just love sport
yeah and we love being outside changes
these days like no kids are outside at
the moment but back then I would play
test Cricket with a
piece of wood we found in the bush all
day and I'd be fielding all day because
my brothers were bullies and that made
me Bowl all day but um
yeah it was it was an interesting
lifestyle but something that I'll I'll
always be grateful for because yeah I
just had love and support and
although it was a lot of disruption like
I love to all the time but yeah you know
I just want to tell that story because
anything's possible yeah so cool did you
find all that moving hard for you to
grow friendships and like how many times
would you sounded like 20 plus all the
time we moved plenty man
um it was hard it was hard but uh like
we just didn't we didn't need friends I
had a big family so like well my
brothers and sisters were kind of my
mates and
um we're changing schools and stuff yeah
changing schools I went to a while
primary I went to Fraser Town primary I
went to Parkville
um where else I go do they all claim you
as there yeah they do they do most of
them claim but um I don't mind her I'll
go back and yeah because my wife was
she's from Gisborne so we used to drive
through fresertown primary be every
summer and because we're going to Lake
wakarimuana that's our like that's our
place we get to and just get away and
phrase Town primary is right there and
uh waikato mwana was right there and we
used to stop in and say g'day and it's
amazing when you walk in there now
you're like how follows this place yeah
back then you thought it was the biggest
school you've ever been to but it's
actually quite tiny so yeah I love to go
back and reconnect and just give back to
to these schools as much as possible
it's particularly um my high school
little fun College which changed my life
yeah I feel so when did you go there I
went to learn as far in college in 2002
and and what changed my life Bros and it
was an interesting kid growing up like I
had a lot of talent but um I was pretty
easily distracted yeah
I was in my intermediate years like I
was sleeping on the street
um I used to tell my mom I'd stay at my
mate's house used to tell us mommy was
staying at my house and then we'll just
go biking into town and we'll sleep at
the library and Hastings there why is
that just because we thought it was cool
oh yeah and drinking or whatnot yeah so
what we do would get a 10 bucks ten
dollars I don't know where it came
wasn't my house but so it had 10 bucks
and we'll go sit outside the bottle saw
and someone would go and we're like hey
mate
can you get us a bottle and I'll be like
hey and then you need to keep doing that
for the hour and then someone would
agree to it and they'd go in and get us
a bottle of Mad Jacks I don't know if
you remember Mad Jacks but Mad Jacks or
Kentucky gold back in those days just a
big hot bottle it was so bad but would
get this bottle 10 bucks a bottle of
whiskey bourbon whatever go back to the
school and just do like nips yeah we're
idiots just thinking we were cool
and then go sleep at the library because
we weren't allowed home because there's
only way we're allowed to go out there's
pretend we're staying at each other and
back then like phone lines were
non-existent in my house couldn't pay
the phone bill yeah so there's no way of
finding out just had to take our word
but we're mischievous as anything and we
went and did that and stealing you know
got got a two-year ban from Kmart native
jokes I can't believe I'm telling all
this why did you steal
ah you remember the old Simpson socks
back in the day like these Homer and
stuff Homer Bart Simpson like the socks
we used to go with socks shovels down
there down the undies and you just go
here die because in the holidays you die
here blonde but yeah because I was Maori
and King it we spent orange so he did
the old Orange
um hair dye I remember when I got caught
actually I got caught and that's why I
got a two-year band is
I got caught putting the socks in my
undies
and they come up to me and they're like
we saw you stealing blah blah and I was
like yeah sorry sorry but they didn't
even know they didn't realize that
underneath I had a singlet I had pair of
shorts on like I'd put all these clothes
underneath my school you know yeah and
uh they didn't search me but they gave
me a two-year van and they got the socks
back but the socks and socks yeah got
home and I still had a full cat oh man
like so that's that's the kind of line
and track I was hitting down as a young
kid yeah just had the potential love you
know late blooming rugby and I had an
opportunity but uh without without a
doubt if I didn't go to Linus Farm
College I would have continued down that
that down that journey of just stealing
um you know I would have been smoking
weed drinking and probably would have
had not not going to be ashamed of I
probably had 10 kids but you know like
bits are kind of life I was I was ever
heading towards so I had an opportunity
to go to private school businessman
College in my
um third form year was this a
scholarship yeah I got a scholarship how
did you get there like
so well it's not education
stealing drinking sleeping in the
library I was a young Maori kid yeah
yeah I was a young mother kid and I had
a lot of um
people and that I play I played for this
raw Shield team uh Hastings East and but
this is a the railway lines and Hawkes
Bay are the separation so you hate
piercings West you've got Hastings so on
the east side there's Hastings
intermediate so that was my intermediate
but there's also schools like hero worth
here with intermediate which is a
private intermediate and then
um you know Havelock North so really
kind of proper prestigious kind of
intermediates and so I had a really good
family orientated team that I was
amongst but obviously I was heading in
the wrong direction so a lot of these
kids went to London's Farm College
and they just get put in the good word
for me and they kept approaching my mum
and dad and saying look I think as he's
got so much potential the school would
just do him wonders
um the only way I could potentially it's
like 20 000 a year so it's very
expensive we haven't had 20 000 to take
me there but I got given a scholarship
called the tafiti nuiatoi scholarship to
head to Linus farm so I had an
opportunity and I had a decision to make
whether I go to school with all my best
mates and go to Hastings boys or I make
the decision to go to Learners Farm
College only opportunity only option I
had to go to learn this one was to be a
border
loves and Hastings so I had I went to
this boarding school I made that
decision I went to Linus Farm College I
went to this boarding school and wow we
was at a wake-up call for myself going
from doing what I want to being told to
get up go pick up the rubbish go sweep
the driveways go change all the seniors
uh get all the seniors laundry put on
the laundry go set up the dining room
table like it was a big wake-up call for
me yeah but I took a few years to get
used to it but without a doubt saved my
life get into that school just saved my
life because I was here in the direction
that right now I don't mind sharing yeah
but wasn't proud yeah so why did you
choose to go there like it must have
been a tough decision like I hate of the
easier option to stay so what what was
the deciding point for you did you just
think you didn't want to go down that
route you were going I'll be honest I
got forced
So when you say it was your decision I
kind of got four yeah mum was begging me
just give it a chance let's give it a
shot yeah you know I was leaving my best
mates they were going to this other
school ah okay I'll give it a chance so
I lasted one year in third form at
lindisfarne college
and then the end of the year I was like
decided to catch up with my mates gotta
catch on my mates I came back to mum I
said Mom I want to get Aces boys I'm
done you know I've had enough I hate
boarding and I ran away from the warden
house for the first two weeks I was not
real bad homesickness yeah stay at the
library
my nan lived up the road 200 meters so I
ran there every weekend or every night I
had an opportunity to ran away so I
struggled for the first year but the
second year I said I want to go to
Hastings boys she said well
you got an option here you give it one
more crack you can be day boy or you can
go to Hastings poison and that's enough
and uh so she generally genuinely wanted
me to stay there so I said okay I'll
stay there but the only downside to it
was mum worked there like 4 or 30 or
five in the morning oh yeah so I had to
go to school for my in the whole four
from year at five a.m and I'll just go
hang out in the gym and just shoot hoops
and just sit there and I felt like I
lived at that school I was there for
that long so that was the only downside
and then I got to the end of the year I
just turned a corner and and just seen
the good that the school was absolutely
doing for me and and the reasons why I
needed to stay there and then my fifth
one year I went back to the boarding
house and stayed on and had the best
three years of my life and yeah very
very grateful that Mum stayed true and
Linda's fun actually stayed true and
and keep the faith in me and yeah and
here I am today that's so cool and is
that when sport took over like that sort
of fifth form yeah is this when you
became to start I remember you're
playing for Hawkes bad about 15. so made
it must have been about this time
um full form was actually the year I
started making a change it was it I made
the change in cricket actually oh yeah I
love my Cricket playing up playing in
high school absolutely dedicated to the
sport I used to try and whip it down
there you're building 140. yeah it's a
ridiculous age I was waiting to see it
on the black Clash but I said it's I've
only won 40 back then but I was about 38
kilos lighter so I could move but not
these days
um so yeah full form I actually just I
started playing Cricket I made the first
11 in full form and then I got a crack
to play first 15 at at four film as well
so that's crazy
but I was only allowed to play one so uh
the coach had to go and beg my mum to
play and Mum said yep he can only play
like one or two games and that's it did
you know you were you were gifted or
yeah honestly everyone else I never I
never had that belief I still don't have
the belief now like you struggle to
believe in yourself
I don't believe until it actually
happened yeah so you get announced you
know like back then you're just a kid
playing the game and you love it but
reaching those Heights that I was able
to was
just felt too far away you know I like
unachievable for for me a young kid from
Hawke's Bay that
you know grew up with uh
the things that I've seen and been
through like you know how am I going to
be able to achieve it so I didn't
believe it or think it was going to
happen until it actually
happen so
um yeah started from a young age just
played throughout the high school and
and then in my seventh form year I got a
contract to play for Hawke's Bay and
that kind of made my decision up for
what I want to do and
that's the reason I got kicked out of
school early because I didn't go to
school in my civil form year so I got uh
I've got shafted really because you were
playing at your PC at the time how bad
is this like a seventh form my wife
Daisy she just left school and she was
at EIT but I was staying with her
we get called into a principal's meeting
with the principal my girlfriend and a
student getting coupled into these
principal's office so she has to he's
trying to encourage Daisy to make sure I
turn up the side sure because that was
like the the contract like is he yeah he
can play for Hawkes Bay magpies in the
Sim form yeah but he's still got to come
to school yeah man I was training at six
a.m I'll finish at eight and then I've
got to go to school and listen all day
but
so when did you get together with Daisy
oh young man we've been together for 18
years 18 years 18 years half my life met
her at 16.
16 man like so
you met her at high school she was uh I
was fifth forms or sixth form fifth or
sixth woman she was seven forms so she
was a little bit older than me and yeah
met her at high school and and just
being together forever and the reason I
love Daisy is
like she's been there from the start
yeah you know she's been there from when
I was getting her to drop me off and I'd
say Yep this is my house
and then she'd drive off and then I'd
run to my actual house
I've been a giver for that long like on
the weekends
no money yeah but she'd take me down to
the local Kebab Stock Shop would have um
you know TV3 movie night and we'll go
home she would shout me kebabs uh we
went for our one year anniversary at a
place called corn exchange and we get to
the end and I'm doing the Haka because
I've got no cash
got a toilet here come back and she's
paid the bill like she's been there from
the start she's been through all the
roller coasters of emotions success some
some adversity yeah
um and she's given me the greatest gift
I've ever ever had with two beautiful
kids so
18 years mate she knows everything so
she'll know if I'm lying on them
right that is a that is an achievement
18 years that's impressive mate I don't
know how how she stuck with us
but then you get contracted by Hawke's
Bay you play
um your first NPC game at what 18 or
might even have been younger but and
yeah you look natural out there straight
away how was it how do you feel playing
that first game at such a young age I
was nervous man yeah absolutely nervous
because I've gone from playing kids
teenagers to fully grown men and
plan against counties Manukau you know
is that your first game yeah like it was
um it was a pretty
pretty rude awakening form for myself
like just a young kid that loved playing
the game to actually having to be
fully committed like I never went to the
gym that's why I still look like this
because I still don't go to the gym like
going from just being a kid that love
playing rugby to actually having to be a
professional was was a difficult
transition and then you're facing these
these fully grown men and man they're
just so much bigger faster and
and you're just wondering how am I going
to go so in my first year I actually got
knocked out like five or six times true
yeah and those are the days where you
just roll straight back in yeah there's
no like
hia protocols or anything like that like
you just oh you'll be right make it up
and go again next week so I got knocked
out big time and that's
uh Mike Anthony he's the high
performance officer for nzr he's on the
case study of why they have limited
numbers uh minutes for players that are
playing at a young age yeah yeah because
of what happened to myself yeah because
I actually got knocked out and just
continued to play and I got knocked out
in a nothing game against counties
Manuka and I actually missed playing for
New Zealand schools in my final year so
one of the one of the hard times and it
was pretty tough I want to play for New
Zealand schools with all my best mates
and
I wasn't able to because I got knocked
out but anyway things happen and yeah
right I'm surprised you never went to
the gym like I remember I remember
meeting you yeah I'm surprised
under 19s yeah
um you're obviously playing I've seen
you on TV I was 10 fall back you're a
fullback and I remember just seeing you
strolling and Matt your arms were bigger
than my legs I was like man this guy is
an absolute gun I won't be able to go
for fullback I might as well try 10 and
that was uh Phil's Grant Dunes at Hawkes
Bay magpies like yeah he we trained hard
like when I made it that's when I
started training oh yeah and putting my
body and and go in the gym like every
day and running and doing what's what's
needed because you just can't get by
like some of these athletes I'm looking
on the Walmart they're just absolute
specimens yeah so I started late gyming
late but um you just have to have to
commit to it and get through it and
spend those spend the money in the gym
so we make you a game and did you start
feeling more confident the more you're
playing or you sort of spoke about
before you had this self-doubt all the
time did was that whole way through or
did did you start getting more confident
after performances I don't know that
self-doubt will always be the I feel uh
look I guess when I was younger I
probably had at least because there was
no expectations there's no pressure on
me and you know I'm just a young kid
that's going out there to play and no
one's you know that's all you play like
and you just play free world free
spirited and you just want to go out
there and and do what you do but it's
not till you get older and you get more
experience the the external pressure you
put on yourself you know the
the um pressure that people from the
public put on you as well so you but I
look at pressure as
pressure is probably more pressure from
yourself to perform like yeah you think
pressure is as more than it actually is
and I think that's the kind of learning
curve that I had to be deal with when I
got older like you felt like everyone
five million people were watching you
judging you every single move you drop
the ball you're thinking what stuff
article is going to be written but
that's what was going through my head
and I think that's what kind of made the
self-doubt more than it actually was
yeah so I had to learn a lot but back
when I was younger man like I just
didn't have care in the world I have no
kids I had no Bees I was just playing
rugby getting paid and driving around in
the car never had a car and and doing
things that I never thought I'd ever
ever do so back then I was just young
and just played and really had some fun
with it and the rise happened pretty
quick for you to a like you went from
NPC to Super to all black yeah oh really
quickly so how was that rise obviously
Highlanders to start a lot of people
forget that yeah started off as a
Highlander but through it all started
for you yeah the Landers the Landers
love the rice it was it was an
interesting one I remember
Hawke's Bay having a weak crack there
and then how to go at the under 19s and
we went over to Belfast and then that
fell into place and
and then that finished and I was
thinking man I'm playing for Hawkes Bay
again what's going to happen next and
then I got a New Zealand New Zealand
Sevens that's right NZ Seven's throwing
at me an odd a young kid thinking all I
heard about was touch yeah touch you're
gonna be running this you're going to be
just running all every single day I got
the call from Gordon titchens
Hey Izzy um Gordon touch and see I'm
like
are you gonna touch what do you want
uh do you want to come have a crack at
New Zealand Sevens I was like oh yeah
okay
um went into sevens and absolutely loved
it yeah he absolutely loved it the
trainings were just crazy crazy hard and
um and tough but mate what an
opportunity for a young 20 year old to
travel around the world you know my
first tournament was in Dubai you know
Dubai play 7z and then jump on another
bird and fly to South Africa yeah you
can get us ever come back out of Hong
Kong go to Adelaide go to United States
plan San Diego go to Scotland England
like it was just crazy so that was a
whirlwind year but at the end of that
year I was like
I cannot do this again anyway reason the
only way I'm going to stop doing this
again is crack Super Rugby
so I just went handy at itm and went
hard played some some nice solid rugby I
was actually in the um hurricanes region
yeah and back then my dream was to play
for the hurricane sure I was young man I
can't go to Hurricane you know among
other hurricanes bus going through the
Hawkes Bay Christian Cullen Jonah I was
thinking man I wanna I want that yeah I
want that and I was hoping and praying
that I'd get picked up for the
Hurricanes but no they checked me in the
draft so back then they take
um why should I don't know some guy
Corey Jane probably
um but you can only secure a certain
Mountain players yeah in your region and
then they get thrown in the draft so
that's the reason I went down to the
Highlanders Pete Russell got an
opportunity to coach down there with
Glenn Moore and I got thrown in the
draft I went to the Highlanders and uh
absolutely loved it loved it two years
down there I played 2009 and at the end
of that year actually the Crusaders were
chasing me and
are so close to signing so close on like
because I wanted to to go and see what
this Crusader's outfit was about yeah
um I didn't I stayed law and I stayed
off one more year and then 2010. they
chased again Todd back at her and and
gave me an opportunity the Hurricanes
Chase again but I said get out of here
you chucked me in the jar a few buggers
though but you went to the Crusaders and
and it's been ever since man 2010 I
moved here and I nearly went to the
Chiefs in 2013. yeah Sunny was yeah
Wayne Smith was here and it was so close
because I wasn't playing well here and
you know we'd just been through so much
and I was living in a shoe box and I
just wasn't really feeling it here yeah
so I nearly made the decision I didn't
and I'm so grateful I didn't because uh
this place has got a big place in my
heart now yeah I'm a Hawkes Bay north
island of the lad through and through
never ever thought I was saying
Christchurch but this is home yeah it's
the same for me so what why did you go
choose the Crusaders in the end like
what was the deciding factor there to
make that move I just always remember
watching them growing up and thinking
they're just so good yeah they're just
so good at what they do
you know they they win they look like
they just work extremely hard and look
I'm not gonna lie they had superstars of
the game plan here so I had an
opportunity to rub my shoulders with
some of the best and I thought I knew
everything I thought I was a
professional I thought
you know I understood the game the
analysis that's involved
um you know what you need to put into
your body recovery just what it takes to
be a professional athlete I thought I
knew that but come here I knew nothing
you knew nothing Jon Snow so so it's
like
um I just had to
um you know where I wanted to get to
this was a great opportunity for me to
to better myself as an athlete but
better myself as a person and that was
one of the main reasons one that came I
just want to let you coaching you know
like you've been the Marco you've been
taranaki you've been
you know the hurricanes and you're
outside looking in your luck
you want to know we deep down we hate
them but I want to know why they're so
good and so that's why I wanted to to
get an inside look and um constantly get
asked why are they so good
I want to share that secret
that's how you've been a part of it this
it's a reason why yeah but your time at
the Landers you obviously you got a lot
of game time which you probably wouldn't
have got if you came down here very
grateful very grateful for that like I
wouldn't have had game time like I had
at other franchises like hurricanes they
would have had you know as Corey Jane
was playing fullback they had some
quality Winger Zach was there playing
Wing So the game time would have been
very limited so I'm very grateful for
what uh Highlands did for me like they
put me on the map they put me on the map
a young kid and I was playing every
single week and getting 80 minutes yeah
um through and through so oh yeah like I
found a doubt very good it was a hard
decision to leave it was a hard decision
because I knew what they'd done for me
um as a young kid getting an opportunity
I felt like we were close you know I was
playing with Ben Smith he's turned out
to be not bad at all a lot of the
greatest ever so you know we both
started our career there and and I
always hold the Holland as close to my
heart for for the opportunities that
they gave given me
but mate all my mates are at Uni there
so I had to get out of there man it was
yeah I was uh I wasn't a good role model
I was kind of reliving my intermediate
days when I went to Dunedin all the
universities I went to the last ever
night at guardies let's show my age oh
it's true that was a big night and it
was midweek probably had a game
yesterday
so was it like the stories are true down
there they do love their purse they do
it is a slightly different culture to
what it is here they love their beer
they love their booze and I was yeah I
was young so I was mid-week just
cruising around like I told the story
the other day we're on a land podcast
I'll share the story yeah so we were at
guardies that night and it was a good
night big night absolutely heaving the
last night like that is you run those
guardies let's listen you'll know God
it's the place to go down the end of
Castle Street all the students Venture
upon this place and just have a hell of
a night so I was lucky enough to go last
night and we the end of the night we're
walking outside
and I'll get outside and all these
people start chanting is these on the
purse as he's on the purse see it's on
the first says he's all the person
anyway get on this car I jump on this
car and I start dancing and dancing and
dancing and having to eat Boogie and I
don't know what crossed my mind
but then I'll jump on the windscreen I
stomp it in oh that's right full stomp
that's windscreen so apologies if that's
your car I'm so sorry
um it wasn't a student it was this
dumbass rugby player I thought he was
being cool so I apologize for that and
then campus wash chasing me down the
road and I got away oh wow so one of my
darkest Secrets I've told me geez
I wasn't expecting that yeah yes I
stopped this car was this just a chart
the chart got me and I got on top of me
I got fully excited I was like yeah yeah
yeah and then I just got carried away
and so I apologize for that but uh yeah
got chased down the road by campus watch
got away and George and I opened my
flatmate picked me out took me home and
Marissa's history and there's a story no
one knew
but then you okay then you move up to
the uh Crusaders um you have a good year
here and then is it from there you make
the All Blacks or how did your all black
call up come about I made it at the
holidays yeah 2010. so the end of 2010.
So what had happened 2009 is I was
playing I was playing okay yeah I'm solo
rugby but I was a bit bit overweight I
felt because I got got caught up in the
lifestyle so into that year Graeme Henry
actually come down and uh come down and
had chat with us and start talking to
potential players and he pulls me in and
starts coming up to me and I'm like oh
here he is Ted there you go Ted and he
comes home and goes yeah you're looking
a bit Tabby full noise straight up and
I'm like what and I was like if you know
your skin Falls I was I was high like
one one team oh wow like a Big Boy geez
but I'm still moving I still plan all
right so I thought I thought everything
was okay so I didn't make it that year
and they actually took Ben Smith and
Zach Guilford
and uh I was pretty gutted hey I was
pretty deflated so the next year I came
back I just had to make better decisions
yeah what am I what do I want to do what
do I want to achieve so got my body and
neck got my body in shape
um started playing all right
and then got caught up for the All
Blacks at the end of 2010 in my 2010s I
think I was 20 20 21 and I was a young
kid so I got caught up to the ABS and
made the All Blacks and I thought oh yes
sweet is I'll get eased into it but no
first team meeting Mills Molina's
injured Israel dag fullback and I'm like
oh wow so no easy my way into this yeah
and just got thrown in we played um
did you feel comfortable or confident or
no not at all [__] in your pants
shunting man yeah like I said I was like
yeah I might come off the bench and test
three or just ease my way into it and
not fully starting roomy with Mills you
know and then I I was nervous because I
didn't want to let
the team down I don't want to let
Legions down there Richie Dan and
players I grew up watching you know High
School had a Hotmail called Izzy
carter.airhotmail.com and now I'm
playing with them come on like what is
this so I I just didn't want to let them
down I'm gonna let my nation down like
that
and I told him when we were sitting them
and changing room behind us I said to
them mate I said my email is he carder
hotmail.com and he goes
[Laughter]
expectations and nerves on myself and
just the enormity of it like you plan
for the All Blacks a team you've watched
for so long and now I'm out there doing
the anthem and the Haka it was the
longest week the longest game day ever I
was room with Jerome uh Joe rockefaco
and um yeah play our watch score
football tries against Australia now
he's next to me yeah
um so it was a long day but I was lucky
I just I use those nerves in the right
way and I was lucky that the game kind
of went my way and and had a solid
little debut there and saw it it was one
of the great debuts but it's crazy to
hear that you had all the self-doubt and
you're like you're shutting yourself
because you you watch your debut from
far and you're like man this kid's so
confident he's just playing footy he
looks so relaxed and checking out gooses
everywhere just just playing what he
sees and it definitely didn't look like
you were in your head at all like like
you speak about they just give you the
the tools a when you're in yeah you know
like the the training week's just high
pressure
so you kind of get to the game it's it's
a it's a breeze and the ages it helps
you know because you're young and
although you want to do well it run
doesn't really know if you are gonna do
well or not so you don't have that that
pressure or
or you know expectations on yourself so
I guess when you're out there and you're
young just go out there have fun get the
porn and run and I if the first kind of
play comes off or you have a little bit
of gold in that first movement
I feel like I'm one of those players so
you got under my skin really so it's
going to be a long day because if I got
off to a flyer come stay with me now
because I'm gonna go handy so that's
what CJ told me here you go that's what
CJ told me so if you're playing golf
with me get under my skin if I shank it
it's gonna be a long day
it's so good but your all black career
wasn't just your day but it was the next
few tests as well against South Africa a
couple that I remember we scored a
couple of unreal tries one I think at
Westpac we throw out a big Goosey on
PSPs and break about five tackles and
score bro if you watch that clip you
watch me and watch me run around I got
no idea I had no idea where I wanted to
be where I was gone I was playing Wing
oh it's true so I was meant to go on for
Mills and Mills go to wing and I'll go
full back oh yeah yeah but I said nah
I'll just jump on the wing didn't even
train there all week yeah didn't even
know and so if you watch it yeah I was a
no man's land but I guess you know Wings
pretty similar to fullback you kind of
just roaming around and and getting
yourselves into positions oh that was
that was just fluky tonight just grab a
ball have a Goosey light I don't know
how they fell for it because I dummy cut
oh and Frank's no disrespect Frankie but
I was never giving you the ball you know
what I mean
um yeah that just happened it came off
and and that's a it was a cool way to to
start the my first try and the black
Jersey and and got it done and then I
was an idiot later in the year and I
nearly ridden dead I'm constantly being
reminded of all that yeah it comes up a
lot hey Clips everywhere on socials
about you talking about oh someone the
other days you know what's that clap
when you nearly went um any Star Wars it
did he goes yeah yeah
I just like to keep you on your toes you
know keep your guessing was it was it
just that you were just nah so
I was young yeah and what didn't think
about the dead ball line or
the moment the occasion of it was 98 000
people scores were locked 22 all yeah 98
000 and I was 21. you're in there yeah
you know you're scoring sounds like that
22 yeah let's go it's gonna be a good
night I don't know why I did it look
it's a bigger it could have been a hard
lesson learned you know imagine hey have
you thought about it yeah man like
imagine being the mug that cost you all
that's a game and you know they could
have had a try and put the ball down
like it happened to Rico a couple years
ago Wellington like it can go the other
way so I always tell the story now like
carry the ball in two hands and put the
ball down do not celebrate before the
try I gotta I gotta
I've got a real growling for that I got
ripped to shreds Mills actually said to
people don't celebrate ever again I
don't even know what it is on about yeah
what do you what do you mean so I do
think of it on the other side like if I
had went dead what would happen yeah
well I would have been a Class Clown
instead of a hero how close were you oh
I was probably like
so you genuinely feel like you
potentially could have been dead I could
have been dead yeah well I actually got
caught up in the moment like 98 000
people like looking around and then I'm
like oh I better put small angles and
then I died and then I was like I should
have died like on my arms but I put one
arm out just to keep it even closer
it just about did go out and did but
race accessory we had a good night yeah
it was a good night a bit and did the
coach just hit you up oh you got sprayed
man I did that sprayed in the changing
room is plenty because
um I'll sit there and typical Corey Jane
fashion we're having a laugh having a
week Giggle and then Steve Hansen comes
and sets me on the shoulder he's like
there you go and [__] I was like oh good
hey
guys don't you EV celebrate before you
put the ball down again don't ever do it
rip me the shreds and I'm like oh
and then he walked off and I was like
let's see Jasmine doesn't he know I just
want us the games
I was like pumping my chest like having
a real laugh and then CJ gets up tells
the coach
um that I said that and then he looks
around and gives me the eye and
all the senior boys sprayed me Stevenson
sprayed me and yeah listen learn I could
have went the other way so CJ do not do
not you know don't share your secrets
thinks he's very he is very witty I must
give him that yeah mate just don't tell
him anyway big mouth oh wow
right and then the next year massive
year for the country Rugby World Cup
year
um were you confident you're going to
make that squad on the form you're
playing
um I wasn't actually no I wasn't
confident like I I actually tore my quad
off my hip that year oh did you yes I
was over in South Africa and we're
playing against the stormers in Cape
Town and I kicked the ball and when I
kicked it I just heard this like Ping
ping that's right yeah you remember that
and I kicked it and then so what
happened is my abductor
I told my abductor off my hip and it
just like flapped down and I was at the
bottom of my knee was this the year you
guys traveled everywhere yeah there's uh
earthquake years earthquake so we're
away we're traveling every week so I did
that I tore my abductor off my hurt I
had to come back and this was like I
think this was about May so I had three
four months to get back and get my back
self-exorted so after that I was like
nah I'm no chance I've got to go get
surgery so they had to pull my hamstring
my doctor up and reattach it and and get
it going and then I had I had one uh 20
minutes of Club
and then I had 40 minutes of NPC and
then I had one test match to make the
world cup so I had three opportunities
and look I'll be completely honest in
that time I was I was living in
Christchurch alone because the team was
traveling every week
so I didn't like when in terms of
preparation and getting yourself back to
where you need to be
I wasn't giving myself many
opportunities I mean like a solid chance
um but some sort of miracle happened
I got I got back I got fit really quick
and I got myself into shape and I got
three opportunities and I played against
Havelock North and Napier for the
Pirates and we won the Madison trophy
there's a bit of a dilemma there because
I came back and and just played in the
final world we actually won it so it was
like I climb up played a plan I won the
medicine trophy there in the bay
um and then I had an opportunity to go
play against bear plenty for Hawke's Bay
yeah 40 minutes with Zach we won that
game and uh had another opportunity to
fly to South Africa and we played South
Africa and Port Elizabeth
and we actually lost that game but I
actually I actually went okay and I
actually played some some solid rugby
then they named the team after that
and uh I obviously did enough and and
that last game to to Warrant selection
for the All Blacks so I didn't think I'd
crack it no doubt with injuries you know
not opportunity limited opportunity to
play any rugby I thought no I'd be long
shot yeah obviously did enough and
and got the job and and then got an
opportunity to plan that World Cup at
home which was amazing man I'll never
ever forget that was eight weeks
of um
intense pressure yeah I know you want to
try and bring up that moment hey mate I
always ask the questions you spoke about
the questions before like 90 of the
questions are about what actually
happened that night oh yes honestly
something you live with the questions
the question without yeah it's something
I get asked all the time yeah and it's
something I have to live with and it's
something I'm very ashamed of because
Mills Millennial that was his week
for his country and
selfish Israel and Corey Jane just
thought would take it all away from him
and take the spotlight away from so I'm
I'm not not proud of that at one but it
was uh it was a tough time and I'm glad
I didn't have kids and my kids will
probably read about it one day and
listen to this podcast about what went
on look we were just young and
no there's no excuse we knew the right
from wrong yeah and we made a bad
decision we're in the massage
and those are the time the days where
sleeping pills were very accessible yeah
we took a couple of sleeping pills and
we're on the massage table and the
reason you take them because you just go
into La La Land and you just you feel
like you know we're always tracing an
adrenaline rush and that was our
Adrenaline Rush yeah took the sleeping
pools and then got to we had to go out
for dinner so me and Corey
and uh me and Corey and Zach went out
for a feed
Three Amigos the trio they call us and
and then it just went blank
and I can't remember everything and you
know I remember waking up
it's next to Corey Jane and look it over
and going
Corey Jane what are you doing in my bed
and we're a like Mariah Living Styles we
have mattresses all on four and Petty
weeper was my roomie
and I was like what are you up to he's
like oh I don't know it doesn't mean
sleeper and I was like oh I'm feeling a
bit unwell I look up and putty goes you
idiots and we're like What He didn't say
anything yeah and then we went down to
breakfast and I was like ah if I'm not
feeling sick I can't eat
and he said bro you must call back not
nine what going on not before
and I was like ah well went to the gym
bro and I was pale white and I couldn't
train I was feeling so Crook and I was
just the worst gym ever I wasn't playing
Corey was playing on the wing so he'll
sweet as he pumped through it I didn't
we'll get back to the hotel and Darren
Chan the All Blacks managers walking
down the lounge walking through the the
full Ernie
knocks us on the shoulder and he's like
you know what's happened not knowing 100
not knowing what a winner did you have
any idea no clue what was your last
memory was it the dinner being at the
dinner falling off my seat
can't remember I think sure and then we
walk in and he's like man you didn't pay
for your taxi last night taxi what taxi
doing I can't even remember a taxi
he's like yeah you didn't pay for your
taxi um the hotel's fixed it up so uh
just make sure you hit up and pay for it
yeah oh sweet yes nice we'll go back to
the room
next minute
knock on the door media manager Joe
Locke
sup Joey come on brother he's like what
have you idiots been doing we're like
what and he was like mate there's photos
there's footage yes everything of you
boys in town in takapuna at the max
Brewery Bar behind the bar one gender
warn that near
serving beers behind the bar and we're
like hey I do not remember a bar yeah
one but and uh
yeah so we went to this bar we're behind
the bar can't remember and then there
was photos of that and then um
oh there was just a lot of time there
that just went blank can't really
remember and woke up the next day and
that all came out that's uh Corey Jane
and Israel dag were in town
um absolutely Hemet
and can't remember any of it and keep
getting repeated and the worst thing
about it is I'm not proud of this and
it's it seems like an occurring theme
but I was like where's my car
outside
that's not outside
so I walked down the bar
Kazi keys in it windows down side driven
there oh yeah bro so
could have killed someone man so dumb so
dumb
um you're not something I'm proud of
feel embarrassed actually talking about
it yeah I've never really shared the
story but it's uh it was a learning
curve for me and and you know just had
to really grow up and the worst thing
about it is my wife was like come out
for a dinner with us tonight hun and I
was like nah now I'm just going to
prepare for the quarterfinal
World Cup quarterfinal this week I said
no just chill
I had to come clean straight away
because front pages the next day so I
let it down light to her and
said I was doing something different but
I didn't and um yeah that was a
quarterfinal World Cup next week got
absolutely sprayed made to feel about
this little in front of the team Richie
Brad Thorne Kevin Milano pretty much now
knocked our blocks off yeah was did you
have to go what sit down with the
leadership group or how did how did it
work oh so back then Wayne Smith wanted
us gone but we're out of the team one
has gone out of the team but because it
was World Cup you can't bring people in
and out oh wow so yeah
stuck with us right otherwise
World Cup winner no chance yeah I would
have been out the back door but he
couldn't so
we hit stay in and with copper we got
just ripped the shreds for the whole
start of the next week we were playing
Australia in the semi-final and then
I would never played the World Cup
anymore if it wasn't for Mills getting
injured in that in his hundredth game he
broke his um I think his hand or
shoulder something happened and he uh he
got injured so I got an opportunity to
to play against Australia and the only
way you repay the faith
for your teammates is playing well I was
under so much pressure man so much
pressure and mink or Jane um had our
best game that weekend against
Australia yeah so I've repaid the faith
but it was a hard week man hardest week
I've ever had and and footy because
I knew I'd just done wrong yeah and I
felt that but that big
but anyway after the game Wayne Smith
walks in we just carved up or played
well we've been Australia probably my
most clinical game I've ever played a
rugby and he just picks up a power and
throws it at me says drink it
and then after the finally he's like
you're lucky you played well
so smelly it wasn't uh I felt bad
because I lit smelly down that's a guy
that's done so much for me but um yeah
not a proud moment there's you know a
lot of a lot of
blankness there yeah it's scary that you
can take a couple of pills like that and
then just go into some mode which you
cannot remember you don't even I can't
remember being at a bar yeah but behind
a bar like
but they had all the footage and then
all the have you seen the footage have
you seen some stuff from the night and
being like yeah what and like someone
I've met people down the down the road
and they're in the bar and they were
like they said they're talking to me
yeah and they're like you made no sense
oh true you just blank and I was like oh
my God they're so embarrassing so yeah
Lessons Learned
um some some errors I've made along my
journey and I'm not proud of but
you've got to get through them and get
through a bit of adversity and and yeah
that was was sleeping pills and
Tramadols and all that big part of it's
a big part of rugby men yeah it was a
big part of rugby because like you're
stuck in these hotels there's no excuse
but there's a lot of external pressure
that's put on you so for us it was a
legal way of getting away like getting
away from her all yeah we abuse it no
doubt and it was I've cracked down on
now which is which was needed because it
was yeah the labs were abusing it yeah
and using them for the wrong way and you
know simple things as some guys wouldn't
take them so you'd be like can we have
them
yeah okay and then oh gosh don't get me
a couple don't tell them for me you know
just certainly boy thanks man yeah oh
yeah not proud of it and um I'm always
gonna say it because it's something that
I'm quite embarrassed about yeah as a
father now you know yeah you kind of
think imagine if your kids or you knew
your kids were doing that and
I'll show them that that clipping one
day and say don't you do this
[Laughter]
but you've come out
um
quite recently around you suffering with
depression yeah was was that all part of
it like was the sleeping pills was that
all part of the Escape or when did you
start noticing your head depression or
you were suffering with mental health
um it wasn't until I finished day like
oh true just just going well that's when
I really noticed because I just wasn't
motivated and I didn't want to get out
of bed and I was wondering why I just
wasn't feeling happy yeah because but on
the outside looking in I had everything
I could ever dream of but on the inside
I couldn't find that one thing that
could make me happy you know getting up
and seeing my kids wasn't making me
happy and and I guess it just stems from
just kind of understanding my purpose
now you know to me Bateman spoke about
there like your identity and and for me
rugby was my everything and it's all I
knew and that's all I thought I was
and it was and when you finished that's
all taken away and you're like okay what
now what do I do now so it was kind of
which is hard for me to Fathom because I
had a job at sky sport and I was still
on the screens
but uh yeah I just didn't I just felt
like I didn't have a purpose and an
understanding and and a real reality of
who I am yeah I know I am as a person
and my identity and I'm still working on
it I still have so much South uh
self-doubt on myself like yeah that's
because I'm in an industry now where
it's kind of you are getting
you are getting judged yeah with
everything you do anyway yeah you know I
was getting judged on TV when I watched
the way I was broadcasting like I'm the
most I've got the most fluent accent or
I don't have the biggest vocabulary
there to to get me through and and I
felt like I was getting judged for that
yeah the way I was calling games I'm
getting judged now I'm hosting a radio
show and if things don't come out the
right way you seem you've been seen
there's like you're dumb yeah and you
don't even know how to speak so there's
still a little bit of that anxiety that
goes through through me on a daily but
I'm in a better place I'm in a better
place and I think the thing that needs
to work for me is I need to be active
now I've been dealing with weight
problems since I finished rugby and it's
it's hard like I said go and see people
now and they're like geez you put on the
beach and I I'm I can take it but I'm
like man if you say that to the wrong
person like
could go pretty yeah pretty pear-shaped
I feel like they say that to anyone like
you go either way like well you haven't
I've gone skinny everybody says geez
you've lost weight where's all your
where's all your muscles gone and I like
you look at Karen Reed I know he gets it
as well Richie these guys who go the
skinniest side but you know one thing
I've noticed what Fords go the other way
back the other way man we've always been
skinny our whole careers when we finish
we're like
when they they had to put maintain the
the bulk they go the other way what is
that
sure way that's except for me yeah I was
always trying to bulk and like once I've
stopped them like it's gone so skinny
but uh yeah that's all part of it
but it was like yeah it's it's a hard
one like if you look good you feel good
about yourself you're going to have nice
self-esteem yeah and you're going to
feel good so for me it's just trying to
find that balance and and put goodness
in my body and and maintain a physical
lifestyle because something I've done
forever and when that's taken away from
you it's hard yeah so how did you handle
injuries and stuff throughout your
career you know when you that has been
taken away from you for sort of six
month periods instead of you know the
end oh look it was it was difficult
um because you always wanted to play but
I I tell the story now to players that
are suffering long-term injuries is like
man it's a paid sabbatical you know
you've got to look at that longevity in
the game you're never going to get these
opportunities to have three or four
months off because you constantly just
played mate yeah you never you never get
a paid leave so this is an opportunity
for you to be yourself so for me when I
had those Force breaks I just made the
most of it I got away and I had you know
I just really took a step away from the
game because it's so
in your face this game from from week to
week and it's you live and breathe it so
it's quite hard to to have that balance
but when you when you get injured go
away find some balance give you a good
opportunity to to plan for the future
whatever it is maybe do some traveling
because it'll be a window it's all part
of the plan return to play plan there'll
be a window for you to train extremely
hard so you might have like a a month or
two window there where you can just get
away and and relax so do that work
extremely hard and make there's no
better opportunity where you are getting
paid
to train and to train as hard as much as
you want and come back a better person
and a better player and that's the way I
looked at it yeah is mate I've got four
months here imagine if I can just work
extremely hard in those four months what
I can be and that's what I did in 2015.
I got 100 I got discounted my shoulder
for Hawkes bad just go in dropped from
the All Blacks for the World Cup so you
know I was already lacking confidence
but I got injured I had six months out
of the game I went to America didn't
watch one bit of rugby for a month and a
half two months I came back I had four
month window me and Neil Tucker and John
Roach and uh Simon Thomas the old
Crusaders trainer we just trained bro
trained the hardest I've ever had to
train when I came back bro I was like
why didn't I do this in pre-season yeah
every priest says I'll come back and I'd
have to start from Square run because
you know he might have just cruised
through some he just had a huge year but
I came back after that I was first I was
in the game I had more touches than I've
ever had back-to-back touches and it
just rugby was easy yeah instead of
having to scrape your bum around that
whole field for the first half of the
year because you just hadn't done the
work so I say to players like if you
have a long-term injury it's a great
opportunity to to find that balance but
come back absolutely hissing yeah it's
hard for kids to understand that hey but
if you think about now imagine getting
paid that coin to just train fully train
your body for four months I'd be like
man I'd take that yeah any day I don't
have any apps still mate so I never had
ants my whole career so I was you know I
had mud gut stag but mate came back fit
as fit as a fiddle and just yeah
everything flourishing I made the team
again man like yeah my proudest moment
has been doubt that hand off I was
playing poorly I I actually didn't
deserve a chance to spend that 2015
World Cup I was hopeless that year and
it was a struggle and I and I got
dropped and I nearly quit well actually
nearly quit the game and what nearly
fully quick I said today retire yeah I
think I'm done this sucks like I'm sick
of walking down the street
looking at someone and and these are
what's going through my whole my mind
just like oh he's like he's looking at
me like oh this is right there useless
guy got dropped from the all black
that's what was going through my mind I
was like I'm done with that I'm sick of
that I am more than rugby and I just
want to live a normal life and then
she'll say no no calm down just relax
you know we'll just get to the end of
the year we'll go to America we'll just
chill we'll have a holiday and we'll
just get away from it all and just just
relax so it wasn't for her yeah I would
have finished but proudest moment I dug
deep and I came back and I I yeah I just
flourished man and everything started
falling in place and and what had
happened is I put like that pressure I
talk about I put it all on me and I felt
like I was playing for five million
people and and trying to impress five
million people and I had the weight of
New Zealand on my shoulders so when I
got injured and when I when I went away
I just came back and I was like no I
don't play for them yes I do want to
make them proud and happy but the reason
I play the game is for my mom my dad you
know my wife and my kids to be because
my wife got pregnant that Year my son
Arlo so that really brought it home is
okay this is my why and this is why I do
the things and when I make a mistake my
why they they won't have that
expectation or pressure they won't judge
me for making that mistake or dropping
the ball so that pressure that I thought
I had on me was wasn't irrelevant and
yeah that year just flourish I made the
all those again and had probably the
bestie I ever had in the jersey and
and and things it panned out and the
Restless history it's crazy it's crazy
to hear that you potentially oh we could
have missed out on those Glory years
because I would have ended with no title
mate
[Laughter]
yeah true so what year did you win the
title 2017. yeah I won my first title in
2017 with Fraser and uh
was that your last year of super Nana
2019 was my last year so but 2018 I was
uh
how do you say it that was a food bill
and then I went to South Africa in 2018
ah Japan sorry yeah and I came back in
2019 I retired but I was still
contracted oh yeah yeah I'm still part
of the team but uh
so I claim I claimed one three times you
got three rings I got three but Corey
Jane would say Jenny played in one
so yeah I'll claim I'll claim to yeah no
fair enough and that first one what what
one was that South Africa
apparently yeah that was the best title
ah the probably one of the best things
I've done apart from the world like that
as a special day heads to South Africa
and the worst funny thing about there is
raise actually knew that was going to
happen our theme was was themed in a way
that we're again in South Africa and we
were going to go the jungle and we're
gonna go win this title and it all
happened and we went over there and we
won it and man it was an awesome moment
first title you never ever forget that
yeah when in that title you won then
2016. yeah yeah such a special time
right crazy so you know you know lifting
that trophy
I was actually quite happy we lost 2015.
yeah
but it was an unreal game too because
you guys had a decent lead or they they
had a red card and then they started
coming home they came home pretty hard
you had to hang on there in those last
few minutes I went off after 50 so I
can't really claim it my neighbor money
is so bad but I started jamming up I had
to get taken off 50 minutes yeah and we
hug deep and they made a little comeback
towards the end but you know same uh who
was I think I met title someone got a
turnover in the end and
like that's
it's it's because you're a little
nowhere you're surrounded by you know
any enemies and you're just in this
cauldron and you get the game done and
then that night that rest of those days
wooden flights for another day yeah
holes a special time to get you know
pretty tight with the lads Monte Casino
was it yeah Monte casino but everywhere
and then just for our flight they came
back with some KFC oh feed the boys up
we can't leave them getting on the plane
with an empty tummy and just drink the
whole way home I actually combed out and
woke up in Sydney
it was a good trip great trap but I'll
never forget 27 and they ain't so good
oh all right so did you ever think about
going overseas I know you went to Japan
but was ever an option for you to head
over earlier or hit to Europe or
anywhere all right I had a few
opportunities so 2016.
um so 2015 when I obviously missed the
World Cup
if I'm gonna play I might as well try
and plan for the future and have we look
overseas so there's
that was that was you know yes kind of
humming and hiring uh there was an
opportunity to go to Japan and play at
Canon oh yeah where I ended up in 2018
anyway
but there was a genuine opportunity to
go to Leinster Lynn serve in Dublin so I
actually caught up with linster when we
went there at the end of 2016. we played
Island over in Dublin and I went and
caught out with Ethan Arthur and oh yeah
and all the coaching staff there and how
do we look around and yeah that was
probably a real genuine opportunity and
genuine chance for me to head over and I
was humming in a hurry but I just got
back in the All Blacks I was starting on
the wing I was playing well
and my contract had a lot of what-ifs in
it if I did this if I did that you know
if I did this you get this so I said uh
wow this is what I'm gonna got offered
to go to Leinster
if you want me to stay I'm happy I want
to stay I won't guaranteed
guarantee at all so Steve Henson you
know butter him up Steve went over and
and spoke to them all and uh and
obviously got it all guaranteed so I
stayed here and then
funny funny it happens way the world
goes was James Lowe actually went into
the oh I took your contract my contract
and went over there and now look at
James so they're so happy over here
because these are way better buying for
leanster and Ireland rugby at the moment
James Lowe what he's been doing so oh
that's true yeah I didn't end up going
and well uh I came back here and ruined
my knee and pre-season against the
hurricanes in Levin I think or somewhere
so I can't understand these preseason
games we play them in these paddocks you
know we're High performing athletes and
we go around and I was playing in this
Paddock bro and I was still in a pothole
yeah
and that was the downward spiral and
that's what I did in 2017 playing a
pre-season and living or somewhere for
the hurricane against the Hurricanes I'm
dead at the end and after that just went
and I was down the spiral man yeah
that's crazy oh yeah I'll try and talk
about it because I don't yeah these
pre-seasons are important but maybe just
get them get games where the fields are
top-notch and yeah you know you're not
putting your body through hell but yeah
that's where it happened and
yeah we know what we're at now there was
a downward spiral that's check stuff
I've always had knock me I've always had
a bad knee but that little moment where
I stood in the pothole just kind of
accelerated the the wear and tear and
and left me to where I met today so a
lot of what else going from my head is
that you can tell yeah and what if I
didn't do that I might be still running
around with Sam whitelock no chance
but then you do go to Japan and it was
just with a dodgy knee so you already
had a dodgy knee but they they signed
you anyway you got part you snack past
the need of cool just yeah I told them I
said look I've got a pretty bad knee and
Alistair Cuts here the Old South African
coach was their coach yeah and I went
over there bro and I was like I don't
train
I just like if you want me to play bro I
just got to have real managed trainings
and uh get through it
so yeah I didn't play a hell of a lot
and trained trained reasonable but we
were doing Walk bikes and Rowing so I'd
rather be training but
um didn't play a hell of a lot there
played probably four games I was there
for like three or four months hell of an
experience what an amazing country that
is so it was cool for experience my my
daughter was like three months my son
was um you know a year and a bit Yeah
and
so we flew over as a young family had a
hell of a time the rugby just wasn't
meant to be and then I played that last
game against Panasonic it was actually
met Todd's team Ash Dixon's team and we
got pumped and I got smoked you know it
was stood up defensively again got
beaten and I went to kick that ball and
couldn't kick it and then I just left
that game I said I've got to go back to
New Zealand yeah my knee is not good I
can't continue on went back to New
Zealand seeing Bruce swaddle Andrew
Vincent the surgeons and they just said
look you can't fix it any way we can fix
his osteotomy we've got to break your
leg you cannot play again and so I just
got told I wasn't able to play rugby
again and
yeah true so and that's when the sort of
down downhill spiral happened of
who am I yeah find yourself
um well it's to say you gotta you gotta
earn you gotta gotta work again and yeah
I was just lucky that that sky and I
actually reached out to the sky and just
said look I'm not playing much now you
know if there's any opportunities to
come do some work I'll be keen and
that's how it all kick-started and then
they offered me a contract for two two
years
you mean that happened there now for me
another contract for another year and
then with renegotiating a few things
went on much you know no it's not for me
so I'll just move on so yeah that was
from here I am now we have gone to our
questions we've gone to Instagram uh
plenty of questions have come and for
you obviously a lot of them were about
that Rugby World Cup and said man what a
story that was geez it's blowing my mind
but um the mix next few there's some
good ones in here too um first question
can you bring back the sea City Brothers
hey don't get me started I can't believe
I did that I cannot believe it look we
raised the money for child Cancer
Foundation now what's that's what it was
all about but I've got coerced into that
by our manager Dan Carter and I can
understand what he was doing yeah he
didn't have one bit of imports didn't
put his face on this team so no one
knows that Dan Carter was our actual
manager of sea City Brothers
um so no I wouldn't be not be making a
come
[Music]
but you did do that um in New Zealand
video so that was a probably it was a
big moment for you right like that was
sort of when the World Cup was on
stardom oh you brought it back now you
brought it up so that was at the time of
the 2015 World Cup so all right we're
just done we're just on the campus 11.
for MIB you know we're going to the
World Cup yeah let's go and well it was
real DX not on that plane so I was 11.
it was so embarrassing that that whole
campaign it was all good I got heaps of
flights and got paid for it obviously
yeah but the worst thing was um yeah I
wasn't on that main flight when the team
was flying to England I was stuck at
home look in my lips and look at my
wounds saying I wish I was here but um
yeah so that was embarrassing but it was
good it was good man I I thoroughly
enjoyed it and did you write your lyrics
down to Christchurch yeah we'll do like
the Men in Black dance I can't remember
it one but uh but it's quite a good
party
um a party thing you know I'll go to
parties and
let's get this started but before this
plays the part and open instructions
from your crew all out of towns and
placards to lose items your ball on ball
must be secured and safely stowed under
the locker up a hit under the locker
overhead or underneath the seat instead
yeah this right here I see balsanzo
buckle up if it could shine bounce clip
slow across your hips just make it fits
into it that's something
I do love a bit of live music
head Elijah Taylor rapping the other day
but I think he might have even topped
them
freestyle what a performance but
um yeah embarrassing and the worst thing
is they ask you to to do it on the
flight so I'd get on and I'll be like in
there but hey do you want to do it live
and I'm like by a chance you're all
right play the video
oh yes
um
okay next one oh you mentioned it around
the
the sea City Brothers all boarding but
what is the secret to growing my hair
back someone's asked and talked me
through this whole journey yeah so I've
started a company called identity saw
that so obviously identity initials ID
uh it's just trying to help people find
their identity back I I don't know how I
know what it's like to lose you here it
absolutely sucks
um so just offering the opportunity out
there that there are options to get it
done and
um going board is okay but everyone
thinks there'll be this magic formula
out there this potion that you can take
and and you'll have your hair back well
there isn't and the only way you can get
your head back is hair transplant I had
it done about five years ago and
basically I had the Fue which is they
take a stripper you'll hear at the back
they individually take each strand of
hair they call them graphs and the graph
might have one two three or four hairs
in it depending on on how healthy they
are and then they put these graphs back
in your boarding spots your areas they
do it in a way so it's not just planted
they actually have to look at the shape
the flows a guy called Vikram and
there's teamwork she plant them in and
basically these graphs because it's your
tissue 95 of your tissue will always
reattach and then these hairs over a
nine month Journey just grow back like
normal here and
you're at a stage now or you've got a
full crop and the rest of the history
and I've never thought I could ever have
a fringe in my life yeah now I've got a
fringe and I can shape it I can mold it
I can do whatever and uh everyone asks
me like what is it I'm like it's your
own here yeah it's your hair and they
take the hair from the back of your head
if you look at everyone that is going
bald apart from Willie Heinz because he
shaves it off
um they've got here around the back of
the head so that is the healthiest hair
on your body and it's just like
geography you're taking the hair from
the back and you're putting it in the
boarding spots and it'll grow back
I actually remember like you I think you
just had your um oh you ripped me out
again
you just had your transplant against are
you I was playing in Japan and you just
had it and you're stoked I remember
seeing your face like when we're shaking
hands after the game and you're just so
stoked with your new hair and I was like
oh that's cool got it done that's quite
cool to watch their Journey like you see
it from being fully bald and then you
like going through that because I just
got it done I went to Japan yeah and you
can see like little fluffs coming
through a little floss and in the best
moment in my life was I used to grow the
hair from the back forward and claim it
Forward yeah yeah yeah I cut those bits
off because I hear growing and I had you
know my crop backs so yeah yeah oh
something I'm proud of doing and I think
the more we normalize it
um the better like like I said going
borders is okay but there's a solution
there there's an option there and and
you should be open about going down I'm
currently talking to people when they're
just so embarrassed they don't want
people to know I'm like mate well you're
gonna shave it off and you know that's
okay but yeah why not just go through
this get it done and I've got a big scar
on the back of my head so Fue is that
surgery that I got done but there's
actually another option where I um
it's called fui so they individually
take the hairs out off the back of your
head it's like an apple core they put it
in they pull out the grass that's right
and it doesn't leave a scar yeah and and
they do it in a way so when the hair
grows back it's you don't even notice
it's just spread out across the back of
your head and you don't have the big
scar across your back your head so if I
shave it short you'd be like wow who is
he with an ax yeah because this is a big
scar but you got here you're not going
but we're not shaving at all right if
you're behind me you're no good to me
that's all that matters you know yeah
that's okay well that's okay now so
we're good
oh let's go well if you are balding make
sure you do reach out to Identity and
get that here growing back like like as
you dag hairs yeah look it's discount
codes or oh look after you yeah yeah
okay
because look at that little graying oh I
like silver flocks because that's all CJ
head you know oh here is the bald eagle
bald one blah blah well you're you're
gray and all you ever see you come back
I don't care I can buy that
on everything
like me now yes Sage
okay next one uh what was going through
your head when Pungo got his first win
oh my horse puggle
um pretty special moment yeah pretty
cool like
I've I've never really been into the
horses I like the odd punt but when I
started working with vcnz we talked
horsing all day yeah yeah so it was only
fitting in my mate Curtin actually
bought pangol when he uh bought him at
the ready to run sales he bore all his
mates in so he's a good crew of us buddy
yeah Brenda McCallum
um Mark Francis he's a lady from
Wellington called Nikki cruushank and
Crookshank and she's she's like the
mother of the group yeah we've got Carl
Urban you know uh Star Trek he's Kirk's
neighbor so he's a cool fella a couple
of guys are very elegant and um yeah so
we've got a cool ass group that's part
of this so we're all on this journey but
man it was such a good moment well he
won
and then he got entered into Derby Day
in Australia like this the Saturday they
had played five group ones on Saturday
and then they had the Melbourne cup
Tuesday yeah so we went over and watched
some race in this third race his
favorite wasn't he yeah
um look it's it's racing he raced the
other day he came third he was favorite
again I don't know I think I hopped him
up and everyone follows me it's just
like he shouldn't be better than he is
but pretty cool man I hope you we're
gonna have some fun with him yeah okay
last question for us sorry I've taken up
a heap of your time a lot more than I
promised but uh ask everyone this
question to finish the podcast best
piece of advice you have for a woodland
listener oh best piece of advice oh man
I've been given plenty of advice of my
life oh look I don't have really one bit
of advice that that Springs to mind for
me
but um
one thing I'd say and I struggled to do
it even myself as as is actually
find find belief in yourself and and
believe what you are doing as
is what you can achieve and anything is
achievable like I told the story
throughout this whole podcast like do
you know where I come from when the
cards I've been dealt but I never
stopped leaving I never stopped working
hard for that that goal to achieve it
that anything's possible you know it
doesn't matter what book you are or what
movie that you've been you know filming
throughout your life that anything is
achievable so just keep believing and
it's hard for me to say that because I
still don't believe in myself but
deep down I'll just continue to do what
I do because I want to get to that that
end goal and you may not never achieve
it because it's unachievable but as long
as you stay connected and you stay on
that path and that Journey that you know
is heading towards that direction
that anything's possible so
keep believing mate love it because well
as we've heard through this podcast
you've been and you've been in that
situation like you're in the position
where you you felt like the dream of
being an all black was sort of too far
but like you said you keep believing and
even when you got there you felt you
know it's all surreal and yeah have fun
too like yeah you've definitely done
that I've had plenty of fun man oh wow
what have I done
that's all good man what a lad podcast
thanks for having me bro you're an
absolute Champion I'm proud of you too
man like jumping into coaching is is not
an easy task but yeah absolutely now let
them in and keep up the good work I
appreciate it and appreciate you giving
up your time and coming on the podcast
and like first podcast ever made you're
going to be getting a few more requests
after this this is probably the greatest
podcast ever recorded oh I've just
missed picking up the kids but that's
all right I'll be right right you're a
land appreciate it thanks brother
absolutely
[Music]